during the day catalina stuns with its
vivid colors and vibrant Caribbean charm
a picture perfect holiday destination
for tourists from all over the world but
when the Sun Goes Down things change as
night falls sex workers flood the
squares popular with foreigners many of
them far too young to be doing this as a
DW undercover reporter finds out after
just a couple of minutes on the central
plaza de los coches how old are you 16
how much is it five hundred I know a
place within walking distance it's safe
I always go there the city's booming
tourism sector has helped many families
secure their livelihood but the wish to
escape poverty has created a blind spot
when it comes to protecting the most
vulnerable Fernando who wishes to remain
anonymous was 13 when strangers first
offered him money for sex when I saw the
money I obviously gave in I didn't
anticipate the harm it would do to me
but once you enter this vicious cycle
which it undoubtedly is you can't escape
on your own you need tools and people
who can get you back on the right track
in Colombia prostitution is illegal
before the age of 18 the fight against
sexual exploitation of children is
regulated by law but legislation wasn't
able to protect Fernando and thousands
of others from becoming victims to
shield young people from those who want
to take advantage of them a local
foundation has launched the campaign
lamu de a soy yo I am the wall is a
defense strategy for our boys and girls
in the tourism sector environment there
are protocols and codes of conduct we
ask of service providers especially
hotels to implement in coordination with
the authorities that's the reaction part
but the wall also does important
prevention work and attends minors whose
rights have already been violated
since its launched hundreds of hotels
taxi drivers and street vendors have
joined the initiative one of them is
Victor
he runs a beach tent rental and feels
like much more than just another brick
in the wall Hey look at the beaches who
knew about this problem or a left if we
see something we make sure to tell
people hey listen what you're doing is
wrong we need to protect our children we
can't put them in the hands of criminals
I do this from my heart nobody is
forcing me this is community work and
when I work for my community I fight
with my heart my hands my feet my teeth
all I have control but not everybody is
as dedicated as Victor our undercover
reporter was offered sex with a minor
just meters away from to patrolling
policemen proving once again that it
takes a village to protect a vulnerable
child but only one person to let it fall
through the cracks